whoever's
treating covet should focus on symptoms
and and
vulnerability not on race
the virus is a virus and you can get it
no matter what year
as far as what i know the availability
of the vaccine and covert treatment is
available to all
races and religions regardless of what
you are i don't see why race is always
mentioned now that if you walk into a
clinic you should get taken care of we
spent decades
trying to get away from using race to
judge anybody for any reason and this is
a disease that strikes everyone it's not
that the vaccination treatment is
available only to certain communities
it's available to every community this
matter what we chose to accept i think i
think dividing people up by race for any
reason whatsoever is completely wrong i
i don't think there should be any
discrimination based on medical things
i i think
biden is is really letting a lot of
people down not just people who voted
for donald trump but the people who
voted for joe biden you bet i voted for
him i even got a christmas card from him
i think he's doing terrible i think he's
doing the best he can with what he was
left with i
kind of liked our country the way it was
before no i'm a desantis guy so you know
i'll leave it at that
i think now he's starting to get tough
and he's taking a stand i'm a democrat i
don't think
we're headed in the right direction he
campaigned as a moderate but now he's
governing as an extreme liberal i mean
when you have to keep
getting rid of people and replacing them
with people who actually know how to do
the job
i think a lot of things were left in
hamas we were doing well with trump even
though like i said i'm a democrat and i
think things have gone downhill joe
biden i believe he's 78
and there's 78 younger 78 older and he's
78 on an older side i think he's going
to cause major problems for the
democrats in the next election